As educators, we want our students
to focus on learning,
not troubleshooting package installations.
RStudio Cloud gives us the ability
to install all of the packages
we'd like to use for a course or workshop
using a base project.
This means that all of the packages
we need are pre-installed
in all of the projects
within our shared workspace .
Let me show you how that works from
within our workspace.
We'll click on new project.
This will deploy a new RStudio project
for us. Once we have our project
we can install all of the packages
we'd like to use for our course.
You can either create an R script
with all of the package installations
or complete the installations
via the console.
One benefit to installing packages via
the console is that it prevents
a bit of confusion for your learners.
This is because any R scripts or files
that you create in your base project
will be available to all of the learners
within your workspace.
Therefore, it's possible that learners
may run the package installation script,
thinking that this is a necessary
step in the process.
We can name our project
anything that we'd like,
and for this example, we'll name it base
by clicking on Untitled Project
and typing in base. Before we can set this
as the default for our workspace
we need to make it accessible
to all of our learners
by clicking on the settings wheel, then
clicking on the access tab. And from the
who can view this project dropdown
choosing the Everyone option.
Once our project has been created and made
accessible to everyone in the workspace,
we can move out of the project
and back to the workspace
by clicking on the workspace
name in the top menu from the workspace.
We'll click on the settings
wheel on the top right. And from the base
RStudio project dropdown menu
choosing our base project.
This now sets up all of our
learners with the packages
we've installed, but that's not all.
We can also create a new base project
at any time with additional
package installations.
Because changes to the base
project are not retroactive,
any previous installations will be carried
forward, along with the updated
installations established when we create
and assign a new base project.